et on vient d'apprendre que tony blair
le premier ministre britannique a
interdit tous les vols commerciaux au
dessus de londres
alors on va bien sûr évoqué maintenant
les hypothèses à plusieurs spécialistes
nous ont rejoints autour de cette table
je voulais présenter dans un instant
d'abord un dernier détour un nouveau
détour plus tôt par washington nous y
reviendrons bien sûr plusieurs fois dans
le courant de cette édition spéciale un
nouveau détour par washington pour faire
le point sur les blessés au pentagone
après l'attentât donc par avion suicide
le point avec julien moment un ruban
jaune pour écarter les curieux les
abords du pentagone à washington au vite
pris des allures de poste médical avancé
les premiers blessés sortent du siège du
ministère de la défense
hébétée selon des témoins un avion de
ligne s'est écrasé sur le pentagone
une heure après l'attentât du world
trade center immédiatement ce haut lieu
de l'administration bush a été évacué à
l'heure actuelle un incendie ravage
encore toute une partie du bâtiment
impossible de connaître le nombre des
victimes en ce mardi le ministère
étaient pleins ce centre névralgique de
la défense américaine emploie 24 mille
salariés
une cible en plein coeur de la capitale
fédérale
du coup tous les autres bâtiments
officiels ont été aussitôt fermés